forces is the approval authority
for members to conclude their service no
later than february 16th
this month members appointed by congress
or the president of course
are retained during the review period
the review will apply to
more than 40 committees that currently
advise the department across policy
personnel
business science science education
training health care
and memorial activities uh i think
uh we if we haven't already we will post
obviously the secretary's memo the
directing memo to this as well as the
associated list
of committees that are being reviewed
and with that i'll take questions i
think
lita we got you on the phone is that
right
that is correct um thank you so
uh two one follow-up enough question uh
on the nimitz
can you tell us what the secretary
thinks
about having a
carrier in this fleet in the gulf
um is he in favor of having one there
and
persistent presence or not will another
carrier be going
to the fifthly to um to replace
the nimitz in a second do you have any
update on
the fema vaccine request
i don't have to go into all of it but
just any updates on it right i don't
have an
update on the so i'll take your second
one i don't have an update on the
request that we have received from fema
for
administration supported by
administration i mean the administration
of vaccines
i don't have an update for that that
that is still being analyzed um
uh again we're working hard on this we
understand the sense of urgency
um and i suspect uh we'll be able to to
tell you more
uh in relatively short fashion but i
don't have an update today
on the nimitz um obviously the
the secretary's concerned about making
sure that the
the defense department and our forces
and uh
and fleet forces uh overseas uh have the
capabilities they need to deter
conflict and to respond uh if needed um
it is as you all know um a balancing act
between requirements and and uh the
capabilities on hand
um the secretary believes that
uh that we have a robust presence in the
middle east
uh to respond uh it's it's a constant
discussion that he'll be
that he has with uh the central command
commander as well as the combatant
commanders
uh in other parts of the world uh to to
properly
meet those requirements and to balance
the risk um and i don't have
uh any announcements today with respect
to
um carrier presence in that part of the
world
um and you know obviously if and when we
do have something
uh to announce in that regard we
certainly will
can we follow up with this go ahead so
was this the decision to
remove the limits was it based on any
assessment of the
security situation in the region
especially in the gulf area
and uh should iran read this as
somehow you know a signal from the the
by the administration of the willingness
to
engage more in diplomacy instead of just
show force well
every decision that we make with
military forces air ground
uh or naval and certainly decisions that
you make with respect to a capital asset
like an aircraft carrier and its
associated
supporting strike group is a is a
decision driven by
a frank assessment of
the operational need the threats in the
area
um and um and
also a frank consideration of uh
of the capabilities themselves um and so
uh absolutely the secretary was
mindful of the larger geostrategic
picture uh
when he approved um
the movement of the carrier strike group
from the central command
area responsibility to the in indo-pacom
uh area of responsibility also and i'd
be
you know i would be irresponsible if i
didn't remind
you that this particular carrier and the
strike group have been
uh at sea for quite some time a much
longer deployment than is
typically required and
so there are you know there are those
considerations to make as well
right now the carrier is is uh moving to
support
uh the indo-paycom area responsibility
um and that's the focus right now i
won't get ahead of
future schedules the other thing i would
remind you is and i think you guys know
this that
naval assets are mobile and they're
agile and they're flexible
and and as
you know the navy likes to say they
don't need permission slips to operate
in
in certain parts of the world so um uh i
i think the secretary
understanding all that is uh you know
remains obviously focused on the threats
in the region and uh we'll continue to
address it day by day
uh about what the what the requirements
actually are
yeah go ahead tom get back to the fema
issue
first of all exactly what are they
requesting is it uh administering
the vaccine if that's the case are we
looking more at military medical
personnel
uh as far as the support and also are we
looking at hundreds or
thousands fall parking on on the
on the effort i know you haven't come up
with final figures yet that's right tom
um but i think i can help bound this a
little bit um and i'm
i'm glad for the opportunity um the
request is largely for assistance with
administering vaccines
so these are these would be
people professionals that can help
actually put shots in
arms so following that you can imagine
there's there there what we're looking
at is a
blend of clinical and non-clinical
personnel to do that
um and i'm reticent to get into specific
numbers
because we're still working our way
through this as for
total numbers i mean i i uh again i'm
i'm reluctant to to put something on the
wall here because the
analysis is still going on but i would
you know i i think it's safe to assume
that we'd be talking
in the in the thousands eventually
but how high and where i i just don't
know yet and i i
uh you know i beg your forgiveness we're
working on this now and i
and i think we'll be able to have more
detail for you soon but we're just not
there and the other thing i want to say
if you don't mind while i filibuster
here is it's important to remind
remember that this is a dod support to
fema and to governors and to civil
officials
uh around the country this is not um
we are very much a supporting element
here and and not not trying to drive
uh the actual system itself presumably
we're looking at
active in reserve because the governors
can get the guard from their own states
right
i you know again i i don't want to be
too specific about sourcing but as i
said last week
i i think it's certainly as we look at
capabilities we're looking across the
joint force which would include reserves
as well
whether that ends up being part of the
sourcing solution i don't know yet but
it would be irresponsible for us not to
look at the whole joint force is that
that makes sense jen thank you very much
john um i'm going to take off because
don't forget with
my uh i grab you do whatever you need
thank you very much
uh how will the united states get
involved with the uh
in obama's military kuta do you know
it's four months military coup in right
now
so how are you oh in burma yeah how's
the military going to get involved
i i i don't believe we see foresee right
now
with what's going on there a uh a u.s
military solution or action required
um who certainly
have viewed with great alarm what what
has happened
in burma but uh but i don't see a us
military role right now
jen one more quick has never been
any sign or movement in military kuteh
in the united states
over the past few months
can you can i ask you to do that one
again is there
any sign or movement
of the military could take time in
united states over the past
humans have i have have we seen it
yeah in the united states the movement
of a military
coup in the united states yes because of
the last trump administration
i i no the united states military is one
of the most
trusted institutions in this country um
and i think
you were all here and uh and watched
chairman millie and the joint chiefs uh
how how they
performed and how they made it very
clear that there wasn't going to be a
political role for the us military i
i know jen
john is the secretary comfortable with
the number of national guard troops that
are up
at the capitol right now is it
overstaffed given the threat levels
are there any concrete threats that have
been presented
and what happened to the 12 national
guard who were sent home because they
were flagged by
either fbi or secret service prior to
the inauguration are they being
prosecuted in some way is it a chain of
command issue what happened with those
12 and what were there
had the investigations found that they
either
committed any violation or broke any
laws
so on your let me go second first um i
would refer you to the national
guard jen that's not uh information that
that we would necessarily have here that
the national guard and in this case the
units would be
me i think better serve to address that
as for the mission itself we have a
little bit more than seven thousand
right now as you know not all seven
thousand are out
at any given time they work in shifts uh
the secretary had the opportunity on
friday evening to go spend some time
with them
he was very impressed with um with the
work they're doing
thanked them for that promised them his
support
um i won't get into and i i wouldn't get
into specific threat analysis here from
the podium
but i would tell you that the department
still
considers this a valid requirement
based on the requests for additional
support continued support i should say
that we've gotten from uh federal and
local authorities
including the secret service um and
that it's a it's that work
every day we're reviewing the status of
the mission um so right now we have more
than 7 000
um i don't want to get too predictive
about what it's going to look like
forward
i think but to to go back to what
you know the secretary he as he told the
the national guardsmen friday and he
very much wants to get them back home
and back to their lives and to their
jobs and to their families
as soon as possible but we also have
what we still consider to be a valid
requirement for their assistance and
we're going to have to you know continue
to meet that and i
wouldn't get more predictive uh you know
more than that right now more specific
um
[Music]
let's see we'll go to uh david martin
you are on the phone is that right
i am i think you said in the statement
on the
advisory committees that the secretary
was concerned about the
pace of change
can you tell us that this this review
was a specific
uh reaction to all of the dismissals and
appointments in the final days
of the trump administration there's no
question
david that the the frenetic activity
um that occurred to the composition of
so many boards in just the in just the
period of november to january uh
deeply concerned the secretary and and
certainly
uh helped drive him to this decision
yes um let's see
another one on the phone i have to keep
remembering to to uh
to do this um
tony tony hi john i have a quick
question
closer to home on recusals the issue
came up today
at the deputy secretary hicks nomination
hearing
by the senate armed services committee
has the secretary laid out programs he
will definitely recuse him for itself
from
that are raytheon related f-35
ground-based strategic deterrence and a
long-range
standoff weapon those last two came up
today and the written questions from the
senate
to uh miss hicks so thank you tony uh
as i think you saw the uh the secretary
commit to that he will recuse himself uh
from raytheon-related decisions
uh not unlike in fact the
the same way that uh the previous
secretary secretary esper did
um and as a matter of fact uh he intends
to use the same
sort of decision-making vetting process
for
uh raytheon decisions that secretary
esper had in place
that was that screening process he set
up so staff would be able to winnow
through
uh programs that may or may not be rich
and
that's correct tony the same screening
process he's committed to doing that
he's made
made that direction to the staff so that
he can be uh
absolutely 100 uh committed to abiding
by
uh his agreement to recuse yeah they ask
you is the f-35 though the pentagon's
largest program
raytheon makes the engines for it uh
will he specifically recuse himself from
decisions on that program
uh you know tony let me take the
question to get back on the the the each
is here
uh i but before i do that i just
reinforce that he takes very seriously
uh his recusal responsibilities uh from
uh raytheon related programs and systems
um and so i can assure you that he'll do
that
um uh what you're asking is a broader uh
question and then i and i owe you a
better answer on that okay thank you
i have actually one follow-up on limits
and two on syria so only
does the does it have anything to do
with the rising tension between
china and india that you deployed or
deployed the ship to
india i'm not going to get into specific
rationale for why
a ship is moved uh you know from one
area responsibility to another
we certainly have legitimate
requirements for naval power in both
areas of responsibility um and there is
a finite number of aircraft carriers
available at any given time
and so this is a constant balancing act
that the the leadership here the
secretary has to
test to perform in terms of meeting
requirements with
uh capabilities i would be
i would i would not characterize this
uh as a response to a specific
issue or event or public comment by a
leader here or there
it is it is very typical for us to move
naval assets from one area of
responsibility to another to meet
a plethora of different missions
sometimes it's just training
sometimes it's transit from one place to
another in this case the nimitz
is at the end of a very very long
deployment um
so i wouldn't read too much into that um
but uh but that's that's that's the
justification and you had another
question
that they're having several terrorist
attacks in northwest syria
and on civilians and state departments
yesterday of course condemned those
attacks
but turkey has been accusing ypg for
those attacks and ypg is the leading
force of sdf which is supported by the
united states
so would you rule out that ypg is
somehow behind those attacks
i am not familiar with the i'm not
familiar with the operational
assessments on this and i'd refer you to
the
state department that is that's not
really uh something that would be in our
purview the us military to talk about
um we'll go back here and then and then
i'll go to another one on the phone good
okay thank you very much uh i want to
ask you about the negotiations
on a new coastal sharing agreement for
hosting the u.s troops in japan and
south korea
the previous administration said the
cost sharing agreement was not fair
to the u.s and they said that the asean
allies
should assume greater share of the
burden
what is your position on this issue do
you think that as young allies should
spend more uh for u.s troops
thank you i i don't right right now
we're
i think looking at uh as i said last
week um
uh sort of a global posture review we're
in the midst of
of uh of taking a look at our forced
posture around the world
um and uh the contributions that we're
making um so i'm not
prepared to to give you a specific
answer that uh
right now the secretary uh certainly
looks forward to
um uh to discussing with our partners in
the pacific
asian uh members as well you know that
that's
uh that that's an important part of the
world for us
uh but i'm i'm not uh i don't have
anything to read out specifically today
in terms of
um you know dollar figures in terms of
of
cost sharing the only thing i would say
uh writ large is that the the secretary
remains committed to reinvigorating our
alliances and our partnerships around
the world and our friendships
because as he said on day one nobody can
do this alone we all need partners and
friends
and you know five of our seven treaty
alliances are in the pacific i'm not
i'm not assuming i'm not suggesting
asean is one of those it's not
but my point i'm trying to make is that
we have many partners and allies in that
region it's a critical part of the world
you heard the secretary talk about the
focus that we need uh
the stronger focus we need to apply
apply to the asia-pacific region
and i think you'll see him over time
continue to um
to bear that out with uh decisions and
policies that we're putting in place
let me go uh let me go let me go to the
let me go to the phone
let me go to the phone
uh carol rosenberg
thank you admiral can you say whether
all the 1500 troops at jtf gitmo
who wanted a vaccine got a vaccine are
all the prison staff who wanted to be
protected already protected it looks
like they're now offering them to
school teachers bartenders and
commissary workers down there
i can't answer the first question carol
i don't know and i'd certainly refer you
down to
either to the navy or to uh to
southern command to speak specific uh
numbers
i do know that um they had begun
the the vaccination of of uh
men and women who work down at
guantanamo bay
on the base and with the the jtf and
they were
moving along the the previous
departmental vaccination schema in terms
of
priority so um they had there are
certainly
members of the military uh that have
been vaccinated and again i'd remind you
that it's a voluntary vaccine you
we cannot compel it but i know that
there were
there were members of the military that
had been vaccinated down there the exact
numbers carol i'm just
not i don't have in front of me right
now but i'll tell you what i
uh we'll take that question but we'll
also make sure that it gets uh
properly staffed through the navy and
through southern command
uh yeah dan can we just go back to the
nimitz just
to be clear was there a reduction in the
threat level
and that was part of the rationale for
that decision or is that not the case
the nimitz again dan i'm really
reluctant to get into specific
discussions of
of threats and intelligence um
we don't make decisions like this
lightly
and there's a lot of factors
particularly when you're dealing with a
strike group that has been at sea
and deployed for as long as as it has
been i think 10 months
or it's about to be 10 months and so
you have to consider the wear and tear
on the ship itself as well as the effect
on
yeah on sailors who are incredibly
resilient so there's a lot of factors
that go into this
and um uh again i i would um
i i think it would be uh imprudent for
us to
to look at this and think well this is
based on a specific piece of intel in a
specific part of the world
it's about balancing capabilities
against the requirements and there are
requirements for
naval assets in many places in the world
uh and then there's a limited number of
aircraft carriers
but i i want to pull back again to make
a larger point
that we have a lot of military capacity
in the central command
aor the area of responsibility um and
we are constantly working with combatant
commanders and in this case
uh general mckenzie uh to do the best we
can to
to meet their requirements for
additional forces for as long as
possible
uh you know against against the
requirement and i just don't want to get
ahead of
the secretary's decision space with
respect to
future naval assets that may or may not
operate in that part of the world we're
constantly watching the threat
we're constantly trying to meet that
threat with proper capabilities
the secretary is very comfortable that
that that process of evaluation
is ongoing and he is connected to
the combatant commanders these two in
particular um
and this decision was made in
consultation with them
and with the the navy so uh
sir hang on a second let me get dan and
i've already gotten here so just give me
one hang on just a second in the center
or in afghanistan
you talked about troops levels and the
considerations last week
is the secretary ruling out the
possibility of any minor additional
forces
because of the situation there either
for force protection reasons or other
requests from the afghan government the
secretary's not ruling anything in or
out then i mean he's
he's mindful of of the need um
and um he's mindful of the threat and
we're constantly evaluating that almost
on a daily basis there are a lot of
resources in the region there are other
resources that can be mobilized if
needed
but i just don't think we're you know i
wouldn't want to get into the specifics
of how that's
uh of how that's uh being done i again i
i i want to go back to he's he's made
this
uh this decision to allow this transfer
into a different area of responsibility
in consultation with both combatant
commanders
uh and with the navy and frankly with
the chairman of the joint chiefs as well
um and his belief is that this move
is in the national interest and he's
always going to fall back on that as he
makes these decisions and again i just
wouldn't want to close down his
suspicion
decision space uh in the in the future i
don't know in afghanistan
he would you would not rule out the idea
of considering at least the idea of
enlarging the us footprint there to some
degree
again again i don't want to get into
hypotheticals as i said last week
any future there's no i don't have any
future force
posture decisions to read out or to
announce
the future decisions about forced
posture in afghanistan are going to be
conditions based
on that examiner i wonder if i could go
back to the guard force posture
in the capitol sure and your cooperation
with fbi as
in support sure can you say whether or
not the fbi has sent you more
alerts uh which come when there's an
arrest
of service members or there's
information about service members active
duty or veterans
related to the capital riots january 6th
and also the acting army secretary
spoke to us recently and did give us
characterize a little bit of what the
threat assessment is in the capital i
wonder if you could
provide us an answer is there even a
threat anymore when you say
you're going to review it on a daily
basis could you then
downgrade the guard presence in the
capital is that possible
again reticent to get into hypotheticals
so let me just try to
parse this out here i would refer you to
the services for
any um any notifications that might come
from civilian law enforcement to include
uh the fbi because that wouldn't come
into
to the office of the secretary that
would go to the services and i'm not
aware of any additional
notifications by the fbi for additional
investigative work on
other members i'm just simply not aware
of that and i would
point you to the services for that um as
i said in my answer earlier
um we're constantly reviewing
the forced posture here the presence of
the guard in the in the
capital region we understand that they
left jobs in homes and families and they
want to get
back to them but from the secretary's
visit um it was pretty clear to him that
they also um
they believe in what they're doing and
they and they and they believe it's it's
a valuable mission
for as long as it is a valuable mission
for as long as is required
this request from civil and law
enforcement authorities the the
department of defense will continue to
source them and to meet it
um when that ends i don't know
um how and at what pace it tapers off
i don't know because we're constantly
looking at this
uh but to go back to what i told you
earlier the secretary made it clear to
those soldiers
that he doesn't want to keep them out
there any longer than they need to be
because he knows
you know they they they're making an
enormous sacrifice and so are their
families
um and it and it's cold outside and and
that is not
fun work and he recognizes that as a
former soldier himself so
um uh we're we're going to just keep
every day you know we'll we'll keep
looking at this and
on the threat assessment i'm just uh
reticent to get into that that's just
not
that's not a healthy thing for me to do
at the podium is to talk about specific
threats and
uh and intelligence let me uh let me go
back to the phone for a second
uh let's see uh paul mccleary breaking
defense
hi john thanks um i wanted to ask a kind
of
in-house question about the executive
order that president
last week about um uh the climate crisis
who is leading the charge of dod to kind
of marshal all the
you know what might get everyone
together and submit that report to the
white house and
and what kind of effect do you think
this new order is going to have
on acquisitions uh operation and things
like that going forward
i missed the question that it was a um i
missed the first part of your question
paul
the it was a directive about what
it was yeah
climate change executive order oh
climate change
okay i'm sorry um
yeah no i didn't get that um
so taking a couple steps back i mean the
secretary's made it clear
you saw his uh statement uh
that he believes climate change is a
national security issue
it affects our facilities and our
infrastructure
that affects things like you know navy
ship piers
and our bases around the world as a
result of the extreme weather that
climate change
contributes to it also is a driver of
of people the driver of refugees which
uh also contributes to instability and
insecurity in places where oftentimes
the military u.s military
then has to uh deploy to support allies
and partners
uh around the world uh and of course um
it requires many times um
the use of uh military for humanitarian
assistance and disaster relief you know
driven by severe weather which is of
course uh scientists have shown is
lately has been driven uh by the
changing climate i don't have specifics
paul for you in terms of
how that breaks out into um you know
right dollar figures right now i mean
previous estimates have
uh have been in the many millions of
dollars in terms of the effect it has
uh on the u.s military as you saw in the
president's
executive order he wants and tasked the
secretary
uh to factor in climate change into not
only resourcing allocations
but operational concepts even wargaming
uh and so the secretary
has made that uh very clear to the
department that he takes that task
very seriously and and will do the spade
work to uh
to do that uh by by the deadline which i
think was
60 days i think it was what the eo said
uh so
uh we'll have i think more specifics to
put on that paul
uh once we get further down uh fleshing
out um
what we've been tasked to do uh but it
you know again
it's a national security issue he takes
it that seriously he knows it has a
dramatic and
and specific effect on the us military
and our capabilities around the world
yeah megan another fifth sleep question
so
nimitz has made its way out eisenhower
is
basically next in line for deployment
and it would be also less than a year
but only a few months
since they came back from their last
deployment has the secretary
in considering these requests from
centcom
to have a persistent carrier presence in
fifth fleet has he
considered the wear and tear on ships
the wear and tear on the crews
doing so many back-to-back deployments
or these extremely long deployments like
nimitz has
is it possible that you could let some
time lapse and flip without a carrier to
shore up the readiness and the morale of
some of these crews well without getting
into
the the specific decisions based on
forced presence in in central command
um the short answer to your question
megan
is yes the secretary obviously factors
in
um the wear and tear on the fleet uh and
on the ships and the sailors
uh just as he would um the
the the um the resilience and the
and the wear and tear on military units
of
all different stripes and it's
absolutely part of his calculus
and that's why before he makes a
decision like the one
that he just made he consults with the
service in this case the navy
and with the combatant commanders that
are affected by this decision
and it is in many cases it's a balancing
act
you have x number of requirements you
have y number of capabilities and you
want to try to meet those requirements
as best you can
um and you're no stranger to the
building you're no stranger to this
this issue there are some times where
you can't meet all requirements
every day and you've got to balance what
what you can apply to those requirements
um and
that is the that's the that's the
business of national security decision
making at the secretaries in and
uh and i and i you know we saw that
process
play out here with this uh this
particular decision
i'll take uh lucas and then i'll go to
the phone good
question on nuclear weapons uh the head
of u.s strategic command recently said
in
an issue of proceedings quote there is a
real possibility that a regional crisis
with russia or
china could escalate quickly to a
conflict involving nuclear weapons
and while charles richard went on to say
u.s military must shift its principle
assumption from nuclear employment is
not possible to nuclear employment is a
very real possibility does the secretary
agree with that statement
the secretary as i think you've heard
him say um
certainly considers um
[Music]
our nuclear capabilities and their
modernization a key priority
um uh he's also said that
um
though we don't want things to escalate
uh
to conflict certainly not of that scale
uh and so his job he believes is to
protect and defend the american people
and that means having a broad mix of
capabilities that
that are ready to do that and that
includes nuclear uh strategic
capabilities
uh and he's committed to as i think
you've heard him say conducting a
nuclear posture review
uh to better understand the state of
modernization
um and the need for innovation and
research and development of
you know of improving those capabilities
uh over time
um i so i think
he certainly shares the admiral's
concern that um that these capabilities
are important
and that and you've heard him talk about
both russia and china
china being the pacing challenge of this
department and
russia clearly posing a threat on many
fronts
um and he takes those he takes those
seriously and as he
as he works through the posture review
of nuclear capabilities and as he works
for
through the global posture review i
think you'll see those things sort of
integrate and come
and come into focus about you know what
kinds of long-term posturing
capabilities we're going to try to put
in the field
uh to make sure again that we can defend
the american people our tensions among
nuclear-armed nations the highest
they've ever been
since the cuban missile crisis uh you
know i try to stay away from
superlatives
uh lucas i mean
again he he views china as the
the the biggest pacing challenge for
uh this department um nobody wants to
see
things uh end up in
conflict certainly not on that scale
but it's his job and it's the
department's job uh
to help deter to prevent that kind of
conflict
um particularly on that scale and i i
would just say that you know that's
that's where his head is rather than
getting into uh you know the specifics
of
most this or most dangerous that uh
clearly
uh there is much work to do and you've
heard
uh secretary of state lincoln mentioned
this uh just the other day there's much
work to do with
our bilateral relations with china and
with russia
uh but our job here at the defense
department is to make sure that we can
protect the american people from threats
uh i'm gonna let me go let me go to the
phone let me go to the phone
uh laura seligman
hi um i have a question actually about
uh guantanamo bay can you tell me please
um who made the decision to
um became fascinating the prisoners um
was that some was that something that
was in the works
in the previous administration or was
that something that the
administration initiated and can you
tell me
why
why what laura why was that decision
initially made
what was the reasoning so i think as i
referred to earlier
um uh there you guys
know this better than me because you've
been here longer than me
that the department had a vaccination
plan a schema if you will for
for phasing in uh the vaccination
of american men and women who support
the military the workforce
different phases the goal being of
course to
vaccinate those that needed it the
earliest and the fastest
you know healthcare workers uh and that
and this supporting staff to them for
instance were
you know right at the top of the list
and because it's a vast bureaucracy you
know
millions of people literally hundreds of
commands around the world
they some areas some commands
move through those phases at a faster
clip than
others but these phases were put into
place
and and developed in the
previous administration and again the
focus was
clearly on trying to get the vaccines uh
to the people that needed it
uh the most um and so
the to your specific question the the
vaccination plan
underway was underway
before president biden took office
before secretary austin
uh took office that's not an imp that's
not to impugn that decision-making
process
at all but just to answer your question
that that was
that scheme was already uh underway and
being executed
yeah wouldn't it be for the sake of the
health of the u.s
personnel there wouldn't it make sense
to vaccinate the inmates
the detainees well the health protection
the of our forces remains a top priority
dan
um and i think one of the things
the main reason why we've got a
temporary pause here down there is to
just better understand
how they move through uh their
scheme how they move through their
phases um
uh and just to take a look to make sure
that
that we better understand that process
again
as i mentioned over the weekend in
keeping with our desire to make sure
that
um that the the health and well-being of
our troops
and their families really are foremost
uh in mind
i think i got time for uh one one more
now
sir i'll get you in the back go ahead
from nippon television very nice to meet
you nice to meet you
i'd like to ask you about the free and
open in the pacific
initiative you know and
president biden and the prime prime
minister suga uh the other they agreed
on the importance of the this
are initiative uh in the last phone call
so i'd like to
ask you how does the dod recognize the
importance of
this and how do you plan to develop this
especially in order to counter china
well we don't have time for me to
answer that there's a lot there um uh
except let me just again reiterate the
uh the secretary's focus uh
on the asia pacific region um and the
many opportunities that are there
and not just challenges again we have
the bulk of our treaty alliances are
there
um we've got serious security
commitments
in the indo-pacific region that uh
that we intend to meet and to take
seriously
um and i think you'll see as the
secretary gets situated
and begins to flesh out uh
what will be the first budget that he
under this presidential administration
submits here in coming months and as he
begins to evaluate the national defense
strategy and as he said in testimony
begin to
flesh out uh what what what changes
there might be
um i think you'll you'll see this
theme come back again and again this um
this
understanding by the department that um
that that area of the world is vital and
will and must remain by we're pacific
power and
um and we have responsibilities there i
think you also heard him say though just
so there's no question that in the in
the
in the main muscle movements of the
existing national defense strategy with
respect to
great power competition and in
particular uh the challenge that china
poses that he agrees with that
okay i'll take uh take a couple more
here
um ellie kaufman
cnn no you don't have a question or do
you
i have to remember to look over here
where it says question yes or no
and that one was a no terror cop
okay we lost here i'll take one more
from uh in the room ma'am you haven't
had a question
yes uh i have two questions on iraq
actually and what iran
iraq okay uh the first one if you can
give us
uh some details on that operation that
filled the
abu yasar laissez last week
was it like a joint operation between
the international coalition
and the european forces
so as i understand it from uh
operation inherent resolve it was a
partnered mission
i am i'm not going to get into the
specific
tactics of what that looks like i'd
refer you to them that really wouldn't
be appropriate for me to
to speak to from the podium but it was a
partner mission
and the second question is uh is the
review the strategy review that the
pentagon is conducting
in iraq will consider the
troops level there are we going to see a
significant
significant change of the number of
troops
that the u.s has in iraq now
i think the current level in iraq is
around 2500 i have no
changes to that to report out to you
today no decisions about forced posture
there have been
made one way or the other the secretary
wants to get
a chance to examine the mission and the
strategy there and make sure that
that that we are executing the right
strategy a good strategy and that we are
properly
resourcing that strategy but he is not
in a position now where he can make any
specific decisions one way or another so
i don't have any changes to force
posture uh to to read out to you
one more thank you very much so in
response to your
uh statements last week here uh taliban
basically
vote to uh fight u.s troops if they
remain in
afghanistan uh beyond uh next
may so the first question do you
do you think the us has enough troops in
afghanistan to deal with
such a situation and are you willing
i mean are you taking that risk
assessment into your
consideration um in this review of
afghanistan regardless of whether
taliban is
basically living up to their commitments
or not look i mean
we are uh committed to a political
settlement in afghanistan one that
includes the afghan government
as we've said many times an afghan-led
afghan-owned peace process and we
we're going to continue to support the
achievement of a political
settlement no forced posture decisions
have been made
and i wouldn't speculate beyond that
um uh we have long believed that
um the the political resolution
uh is uh is the best way forward and and
the secretary and the department
are committed to that okay thanks
everybody appreciate it thank you very
much
thank you
thank you are you doing
you